there is no minimalist rulebook well
until now the minimalists have created
sixteen rules for living with less a
free ebook which you can download right
now at the minimalists com slash
resources enjoy
oh we got a question from tall poppy
what event or person most shaped your
relationship to money that's a great
question hmm for me personally I mean
there's no question it was well I
actually have two people Dave Ramsey
with respect to debt and he you know
just his his simple money advice which
works for anyone whether you're making
$20,000 a year or if you were like me
making $200,000 a year but I was still
broke he has some very simple advice
that isn't easy advice you actually have
to put in work to pay off debt and you
have to live very differently if you
want to get out of debt so that that
shaped me quite a bit also our friend
and my mentor Karl Karl widenar who is
Ryan and I both worked with him back in
our telecom days and he once told me
don't ask a man who makes twenty
thousand dollars a year how to make a
hundred thousand dollars a year yeah
Josh I gotta say it was you brother
you're the one who really helped me
shape I mean you and Dave Ramsey or I
guess maybe Dave Ramsey through you it
really helped me but I remember us
having a conversation where on the
whiteboard you just helped label out
exactly you know where the money's
coming in and where it should be going
out and yeah I'm really grateful that
you sat down at that conversation with
me because I've been following that for
the last you know eight nine years and
it's really helped me to not have so
much stress around money what about you
Chris women see the shape here yeah I
was gonna say my dad I think I was
actually trying to think about for I was
like who is it but no probably my dad
and I don't think he ever like said
Chris here's some money lessons you know
it was just kind of by you know
following along I was thinking so if
some examples so I actually lived apart
from him for about three years from the
time I was like six seven and eight I
was in the Philippines with my mom and
stepdad so my dad was back in the States
and and he would write letters I mean
this was like how it worked back then II
write letters and he would send me an
allowance of a dollar a week
and at some point I got this this idea -
I asked you I was like dad what if you
spent cent two dollars and I used that
extra dollar to like buy something I
forgot how I phrased it but I was like
buy something for you or something like
that and he was like that's a good idea
and he started sending two dollars but I
don't know if I ever actually bought
anything for him so maybe that was like
an early entrepreneurial you know
finisher but the other the story I was
thinking about was so when I was
actually back you know in this case with
him remember he had this example I think
he just like threw this threw us out
like offhand but it still remains with
me you know he was actually pretty bored
for a while and like child support for
me and all kinds of stuff and you know
our big night out would be to go to
Burger King and he was telling me like
he had this car that kept breaking down
you know all the times like an old van
actually an old van it kept breaking
down and he said some of the guys at his
work you know basically had told him
they're like we ran the numbers and it
would actually be more affordable for
you to buy a Mercedes in the long term
you know because of the maintenance they
had this like they were engineers they
were into this whole thing you know like
so it's better for you to buy a Mercedes
than to have this old van and keeps
breaking down and he said you know his
response is that that's great but
there's a problem you know there's a
small problem with that which is I can't
buy a Mercedes you know right now and so
I think of that in the no debt context
it's like what we were talking about a
mortgage and some people say that this
is a good this is a good debt to have
because you know this reason this reason
this reason but is it really you know so
my dad never bought a Mercedes and I
thought about that a lot it's like just
because something might make sense for
somebody else or it makes sense on some
theoretical model it's not necessarily
how it applies in the real world and so
you have to think about how it applies
to your situation right because the
those models don't take in consideration
the these sort of mental calls of a lot
of these things as well the there's a
particular weight that's involved with
with having a car payment or a mortgage
payment and it's not that I'm I'm
diametrically opposed to having a
mortgage it's just that I'm opposed to
having that debt if I could otherwise
pay it off if I had a $200,000 mortgage
but I had $200,000 cash in the bank I'd
rather put that money toward the
mortgage and thus not have that
and have the all the associated cost the
the weight of of that debt and I was
just talking to our mutual friend Julian
Smith yes yes probably the same time
I've known you guys 10 years yeah yeah
he he's up at you know he's the CEO of a
company called breather now but he's the
author of quite a few books most notably
a book called the flinch and we were
just talking yesterday he was asking how
things are going out here and I was
asking him how things are going up in
Montreal and I said you know in a weird
way it feels like I've spent the last 12
years preparing for this pandemic
without even knowing it and he said I
think you have he goes you your cost of
living is is relatively low isn't it and
I said yeah my only expenses right now
are food rent and and utilities and he
goes all you don't even have a car I
said oh no I have a car I just don't
have a car payment and it's funny that
that we often we mistake one for the
other right as a you you should be able
to have a car without having a car
payment if we have a car payment where
we're doing it we're doing it wrong and
and so in a weird way Ryan and I have
spent the last decade making sure that
our expenses are relatively low on the
personal side and the obviously our
business has expenses we employ quite a
few people but on the personal side
trying to keep that as low as possible
so that in a time like this where things
have to tighten up or we may even have
to dip into our emergency fund because
of a true emergency that's going on it
gives me a cushion to not to not feel
anxious and and wonder like oh my gosh
am I going to be able to pay rent this
month well 10 years ago that would have
been a big a big worry of mine and now
it's less of a worry because I've I've
spent the last decade sort of preparing
for for something like this